pour démarrer ce journal les habitants
de de Bourgueil vont devoir apprendre à
se passer de leur patinoire et oui auren
trop véuste trop cher la majorité du
conseil municipal de Bourgueil a voté
hier la fermeture de la patinoire
fréquentée au-delà de la commune elle
coûte 200000 € par an en électricité
c'est trop pour la municipalité qui a
donc acté sa fermeture à partir du 20
avril prochain les clubs de hockey ou
encore de patinage ne digère pas cette
nouvelle Clémence
d'usque colère et tristesse au du
patinage artistique du mercredi matin la
veille la transformation de la patinoire
de Bourgueuil a été votée au conseil
municipal le glaçon fermera en avril
prochain pour certains on est presque là
tous les
soirs enfin c'est c'est une régularité
puis c'est un club familial c'est une
prof à l'écoute de ses élèves et puis
qui croi en
eux voilà en fait en la patineoire c'est
un peu notre café du coin quoi qu'ils
ont recherché une prof il y a 2 ans de
ça et c'est le club qui m'a poussé à
faire mon diplôme parce que il y avait
plus de prof dans le dans le club c'est
compliqué la fermeture définitive parce
que bah j'ai construit un petit peu
toute ma vie ici aussi donc c'est un peu
la continuité mon métier au Conseil de
la veille plusieurs patineurs se sont
exprimés mais le projet de
transformation en lieu sportif et social
sans glace l'a emporté la commune a
dépensé 75000 € dans un devis pour la
remplacé par un revêtement
synthétique la minorité a fait le choix
de refuser de vote
cet aspect concernant la patinoire du
fait que le projet était pas assez mené
et abouti donc du coup ce ne sont que
des élus de la majorité qui ont voté sur
les 21 votants 20 bulletins de vote
sontessortis avec une transformation du
bâtiment selon un rapport de la Cour des
comptes de 2022 la patinoire entraîne un
déficit structurel trop important par
rapport à la taille de la commune de
Bourgueil l'absence d'un plan
d'entretien annuel du bâtiment est
également pointé du doigt depuis la
reprise de la saison sportive 20000 € de
réparation ont déjà été réalisé sur
l'année 2023 alors qu'on a fait des
efforts pour pour réduire le le temps de
glace pour baisser la hauteur de glace
ça c'est des propositions qui ont été
fait par les sections et que je remercie
hein on s'est amélioré mais pour autant
le déficit de fonctionnement donc c'est
déficit général moins recettees c'est
encore plus de 200000 €. la communauté
de commune n'a pas décidé de reprendre
cette compétence entre 2020 et 2026
quant au maire il prévoit de rencontrer
les associations sportives dans les
prochains
jours